sen depuis quelques semaines des
captures d'ÉCR de conversation de MESS
circul et aujourd'hui on apprend qu'une
plainte a été déposée contre l'animateur
mais aussi Koé a déposé une plainte
contre une jeune fille pour pourquoi
Gill il avait d'abord déposé une plainte
pour harcèlement et là maintenant c'est
une plainte pour dénonciation
calomnieuse qu'il dépose aujourd'hui
qu'il va déposer c'est une histoire
incroyable vous allez nous parler de ça
parce que vous avez la version des faits
de de Sébastien exement exactement c'est
incroyable on va revenir sur cette
affaire avec myiam Palomba petit rcap et
B c'est là elle arrive après c'est
par depuis un mois l'animateur cé est
ciblé sur les réseaux sociaux où sont
postés plusieurs témoignages de femmes
et où circulent des captures d'écran qui
indiqueraient que l'homme aurait envoyé
des messages à caractère sexuel à une
mineure mais alors que l'animateur s dit
choqué face à ses accusations et affirmé
avoir porté plainte ces allégations sont
totalement fausses magazine lob se
révèle aujourd'hui qu'une plainte pour
viol le visant a été déposée par une
femme il s'est assis à côté de moi il a
enlevé le bouton de son pantalon et a
baissé légèrement révélation exclusive
après la plainte pour viol contre
l'animateur cé ce soir dans
[Musique]
TPMP ah vous êtes là vous
euh vous étiez là il a jou un garçon
avec une moustache dit B où c'est Miriam
qui s'est laissé pousser la moustache ça
lui va extrêmement bien d'ailleurs ce
petit book mais vous êtes là myiam
Palomba on va revenir sur toute
l'affaire bien entendu ce soir et Gilles
vous avez des
infos toute nouvell he de l'affaire
juste vous avez ça a reboué un petit peu
sur l'affaire Plaza aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui se passe juste est-ce que
vous avez l'info ou pas du tout non j'ai
pas l'info d'ord alors il y a il y a une
plainte je crois qui a été déposée côté
Plazza c'est-à-dire que on commence à
penser que vraiment il y avait un enfin
cette plainte démon qui a un système
organisé chez les plaignantes de
harcèlement euh que des proches é harcé
a il y plainte du côté Plaz une nouvelle
plainte VO trème plainte côté Plazza
voilà c'est la tèse de la défense depuis
le débutou absolument VO du côté M6 ça
bouge pas non pour le moment non c'est
une jeune femme en fait qui qui a été
contactée par sur les réseaux sociaux en
fait par par les par les celles qui a
criminent Stéphane Plazza qui a portter
plainte pour harcèlement aujourd'hui
ouais ça un
oui allez euh on va parler c'est é c'est
vrai que c'est une affaire qui qui dure
c'est quoi l'histoire en fait alors tout
a commencé en fait le le 13 octobre
quand sur un compte celui de de
zoestagan sur Twitter des SMS
extrêmement salass sont dévoilés alors
ces SMS sont censés être ceux de Cé qui
l'aurait fait à une jeune femme qui à
l'époque était mineure et donc là les
réseaux se sont enflammés puisque
vraiment les les textaux qui sont
dévoilés sont
extrêmement explicites oui on va dire ça
et du coup la jeune femme qui s'appelle
sur le qui qui s'appelle jus Honner en
pseudo sur sur Twitter a pris la parole
un mois plus tard pour
accuser Sébastien Koé de viol et
d'agression sexuelle alors qu'elle était
mineure elle a décidé de de parler parce
que elle ne supportait plus de de voir
des photos de lui en vacances elle a
reçu énormément de témoignages de jeunes
femmes qui l'ont conforté dans sa
position et là ce qui est tout nouveau
c'est que aujourd'hui après un mois de
déballage sur Twitter cette jeune femme
a on apprend que cette jeune femme a
porté plainte pour viol pour deux viols
dont l'un alors qu'elle était mineur
samedi dernier donc voilà c'est c'est ça
l'histoire alors euh justement quels
sont les faits relatés cette jeune femme
on va voir la la la la version de de de
des équipes de Sébastien cé oui l'état
d'esprit et la version des
fait c'est une terrible machination
quand vous allez nous en parler Gill oui
alors donc elle a eu deux jours
d'audition le 18 et le 20 novembre dans
cette audition on découvre en fait que
le 15 janvier 2014 alors à l'époque elle
a 15 ans quand elle est elle gagne un
concours pour aller à Disneyland avec ce
et son équipe tout se passe bien et à ce
moment-là Sébastien cohé lui aurait
proposé de venir assister quelques mois
plus tard à un mix à Genève elle accepte
elle s'y rend au moment des fait elle a
16 ans elle y va avec son beaufrère mais
ça c'est sa version ou oui c'est sa
version moi c'est la version c'est la
c'est c'est les auditions c'est ce que
révèle l'audition donc elle y va avec
son beaufrère et sa belle-sœur il
boivent vin verre et puis là cé lui
aurait proposé de monter dans sa chambre
d'hôtel afin qu'elle lui fasse écouter
une maquette et là c'est là où les
choses se compliquent il s'est assis à
côté de moi dit-elle il a enlevé le
bouton de son pantalon il a baissé
légèrement de quelques centimètres en
sortant son sexe j'ai dû lui faire une
fellation de quelques secondes euh donc
donc voilà donc c'est le premier fait
donc à ce moment-là elle a 16 ans et
elle raconte un autre fait qui se serait
déroulé l'année dernière dans un parking
où là encore à nouveau elle aurait été
obligée de de lui faire une nouvelle
fellation alors donc eté a porté plainte
contre cette jeune fille on va voir ça
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe laffaire
après comment comment elle a évolué
alors l'affaire Al lui il a porté
plainte pour pour harcèlement sur les
réseaux soci
il s'est exprimé une première fois le 17
novembre en disant qu'il été extrêmement
choqué par toutes ses
accusation qui prendrait toutes les les
mesures nécessaires pour faire éclater
la vérité
Energie aussi s'est prononcé en disant
que il prenait acte de la sisine des
autorités judiciaires et puis
aujourd'hui Sébastien cohé a publié un
communiqué de presse beaucoup plus
agressif parler dans un instant on va
voir la version bien sûr de du clan de
mais là où ça a évolué c'est que que
déjà la jeune femme sur Twitter a dit
qu'elle avait des témoignages et le
nouvel HS aussi a dit qu'il avait il
disent quoi le nouvels alors le Nouvel
Obs dit qu'ils ont qu'ils ont à peu près
six témoignages de d'anciennes salariés
stagiaires ou d'apprentis qui qui ont
travaillé pour cohé pendant la période
mi mi des années 90 au milieu des années
90 jusqu'à aujourd'hui quand il était à
la fois sur skyrock et energy et il y en
a il y a plusieurs témoignages dont
celui de ha qui avait 21 ans au moment
des faits alors elle était stagiaire
dans la maison de production de cohé
bare en 2012 et donc elle raconte que
que cé était très qu'elle était très mal
à l'aise qu'il venait tous les matins
dit-elle me faire un câlin essayer de
m'embrasser me glisser dans l'oreille tu
es amoureuse de moi devant tout le monde
parce qu'ils étaient dans un dans un
open space et puis ensuite elle raconte
que un jour il lui a demandé de lui
apporter un des DVD qu' aurait oublié et
là il elle se retrouve dans un bar et là
il lui propose carrément de de se mettre
il lui aurait proposé de se mettre
carrément sur ses genoues qu'elle refuse
et puis et puis les choses se
compliquent ça c'est l'article du
nouvelops oui c'est le témoignage que le
nouvels a et les choses se existe encore
sur journal oui la preuve et les choses
se compliquent par la suite parce
qu'elle elle raconte donc av fait des
article sur moi aussi un truc pardon
vous avez fait une enquête sur moi aussi
ah désolé be torchon ah personne na lu
d'ailleurs par person person ne le dit
d'accord bon moi j'aime pas trop la
presse moi vous savez ah ou sais je sais
je sais je sais donc je veux bien qu'on
relate ce que dit l'Obs mais l'obsut
vous dire l'Obs bon après c'est des
témoignages on peut c'est des
témoignages anonymes c'est des
témoignages anonymes par que moi aussi
je pe non oui elle a un témoignage anon
après non non après il y en a une autre
qui a témoigné dans l'Obs et qui aussi
s'est exprimé sur ça existe encore ce
l'Obs je peux juste poser une question
juste une précision parce que j'ai pas
très bien compris le premier témoignage
de la jeune fille Miriam on est d'accord
que donc la première fois elle dit
qu'elle a fait une fellation rapide à cé
dans cette chambre là et après combien
de temps après à nouveau elle se
retrouve à faire une fation dans un par
ans plus tard par en fait ce qu'elle
explique c'est que elle est restée en
contact AC on cette jeune fille elle
avait fait en plus je le savais pas et
elle a posté un truc sur sur son sur ses
réseaux elle avait fait le clip avec
nous pour la Coupe du Monde vous
rappelez ou pas on va la pécho et elle
était avec nous on était tous ensemble
elle était avec nous voilà elle était
très sympathique hein voilà elle avait
fait même des photos avec nous et ca
elle l' posté je me suis dis ah oui
c'est vrai qu'elle était avec nous dans
le clip on va la pécho voilà ah mais il
y a même sur Twitter il y a des photos
d'elle avec Koé mais ce qu'elle raconte
c'est qu'elle était parce qu'il y a
énormément de photos d'elle avec cé
alors
justement qu'elle était sous emprise que
que voilà que en plus il lui faisait
comprendre que pour réussir bah fallait
fallait coucher qui qui a dit alors qui
qui dit c'est c'est dans l'article ça
c'est elle qui dit ça dans la déposition
qu'elle a faite le 18 et le 20 novembre
dernier donc il a pas si longtemps que
ça et donc du coup elle raconte qu'elle
était sous son emprise qu'elle qu'elle
se sentait mal mais qu'elle a décidé de
parler parce que depuis ce ce deuxème
acte où il l'aurait obligé à lui faire
une fation elle se sentirait extrêm
extrêmement mal au point de faire une
dépression et d'avoir même fait deux
tentatives de suicide alors Gilles
Verdez vous avez également la la
versionution vous avez eu tout le monde
voilà j'ai l'autre j'ai l'autre version
sans préjuger du tout des résultats de
l'enquête je donne la version de
Sébastien cohet et de sa compagne
Nathalie avec laquelle j'ai longuement
parlé aujourd'hui et qui m'a autorisé à
le dire est un amour voilà donc d'abord
l'état d'esprit de Sébastien cohet euh
qui était à l'antenne aujourd'hui
puisqu'il continue l'antenne il a pris
un gros coup de Massu euh c'est vrai que
lui c'est un père de famille recomposé
là pour lui ça nuit à son honneur donc
il sera extrêmement combattif ils m'ont
expliqué que Sébastien cohé a des
principes qu'il a de quoi se défendre un
dossier conséquent qu'il réserve
évidemment pour les enquêteurs nul doute
qu'il sera entendu prochainement par la
police puisque l'affaire va prendre un
tournant judiciaire donc lui il a déposé
une plainte pour harcèlement sur les
réseaux sociaux ça c'est la première
plainte et là comme on le disait Cyril
il porte plainte en dénonciation
calomnieuse contre l'auteur de ce qu'il
considère comme de graves accusation
infondée auprès du Procureur de la
République il m'annonce qu'il combattra
sans relâche et Nathalie s'ac compagne
elle elle me dit que évidemment quand
elle a appris ça elle est tombée desnu
et qu'elle a mené sa propre enquête elle
a mené son enquête parce que Maelle dit
j'avais besoin de savoir et sa
conclusion je vais vous parler des faits
après sa conclusion c'est qu'elle n'a
aucun doute Sébastien n'a pas fait ça ne
fait pas ça et ne fera pas ça voilà elle
elle le soutient voilà je précise que je
donne la version de l'entourage de
Sébastien cé he sans pré comme ça on a
les deux versions alors sur les faits
donc eux se sont intéressés au profil de
la plignante et ils ont trouvé des
incohérences ils ont tout décortiqué au
niveau de son âge et ils disent qu'elle
a deux profils facebook sur les réseaux
sociaux et que ce qu'elle dit comme
étant son âge 23 ans 25 ans 16 ans est
extrêmement flou aujourd'hui elle a 25
ans elle est assistante médicale voilà
je je je précise ce que dit euh
Sébastien co alors donc qu'est-ce pass
il y aura un problème sur l'âge problème
sur la incohérence pour l'âge selon lui
c'est-à-dire que on ne sait pas très
bien quel âge à là aujourd'hui 23 25 ans
ce qui ce qui découle ensuite de quel
âge avait-elle au moment des faits
qu'elle dénonce voilà voilà première
incohérence deuxème incohérence c'est
que elle a envoyé toujours selon
Nathalie deux messages à la compagne de
cohé à Nathalie ça Nathalie me les a lu
premier message tu es très belle
deuxième message une autre fois alors
que Nathalie est avec Sébastien cohet je
crois sur une manifestation dommage que
je ne sois pas là ce qui pour
l'entourage de Sébastien cohet dénote
que cette jeune femme ne manifeste à ce
moment-là aucune agressivité envers
Sébastien cet sur son profil sur ses
profils de réseaux sociaux elle affiche
partout Sébastien cet alors vous on a
entendu le mot en prise j'entends tout à
fait simplement l'entourage de Sébastien
cohet dit que elle change beaucoup de
version notamment sur leur première
rencontre la première rencontre une fois
elle parle d'une rencontre en public une
autre fois pour la manifestation Disney
que vous évoquez donc là aussi pour
l'entourage de Sébastien cet voilà de
nouvelles incohérences et ce que dit
infin l'entourage de Sébastien cohet et
natthalie c'est que selon eux cette
jeune filleette je je c'est vraiment eux
obsédée par Sébastien
c'est-à-dire que même cet été selon
natthalie elle voulait le rejoindre cet
été elle avait envie de le rejoindre
manifesté l'envie de le rejoindre
Nathalie m'explique que la plaignante a
manifesté cet été l'envie de rejoindre
Sébastien cé ce qui dénote une forme
d'obsession ils m'ont envoyé ils m'ont
ils m'ont dit que le mot était pour eux
c'est une sorte de groupie obsédé par
Sébastien voilà et les SMS alors il y a
deux versions totalement différentes
alors non je précise je précise que sur
le fond du dossier l'existence des SMS
ils m'ont dit qu'il réservaiit cela à la
justice voilà je n'ai pas non mais myiam
vous pouvez me le reprocher mais je nai
je ils m'ont dit que leur dossier serait
à la disposition des enquêteurs et que
pour le moment il ne parlait pas du fond
du dossier qui sera évidemment instruit
et ils seront entendus ils sont prêts à
être entendus et si j'ai bien compris
l'état d'esprit de Sébastien COH je
crois l'avoir compris c'est que il a
envie d'être entendu très vite très vite
pour pouvoir démontrer qu'il n'y a pas
de matérialité dans les faits et que son
dossier de démenti est costaud par il
parle lui d'une véritable machination
voilà oui il pense que c'est ourd et que
il y a il y a pas eu de fait
répréhensible et il s'estime totalement
innocent je vous l'ai dit hein Nathalie
Sébastien n'a pas fait ça ne fait pas ça
et ne fera pas ça c'est quelqu'un qui a
des principes et ça ce n'est pas lui
voilà ce qu'elle dit encore une fois
encore une fois on est bien d'accord je
donne l'autre version c'est pas votre
version non non c'est de verion votre
version Gilon c'est bienvid ou pas des
résultats de l'enquête j'ai j'ai j'ai
j'ai appelé des gens et j'ai j'ai aussi
je que enfin voilà je je vais pas
révéler le mon enquête mais il y a des
choses quand même assez troublantes
alors ah ben allez-y non non mais pour
l'instant je suis je suis en cours
d'enquête mais il y a effectivement moi
j'ai eu un témoignage en plus de
quelqu'un que que que que je connais
très bien et c'est vrai qu'il y a il y a
il y a des même si CIT pas des
agressions et des et des viols comme
comme cette jeune femme l'accuse il y a
des FA de procéder quand on travaille
avec lui qui aujourd'hui sont
inacceptables peut-être qu'à l'époque
elles étaient acceptées au rien à voir
ça n'a rien à voir avec l'histoire
excuse-moi si si parce que je peux pas
rentrer je peux pas rentrer dans les
détails mais il y a des il y a des
choses qui
voilà mais Nathalie quand quand j'ai
parlé longuement avec elle me dit aussi
par rapport au au autres témoignages si
je pu dire elle dit aussi Sébastien
avant de ils sont ensemble depuis
longtemps avant avait une vie d'homme
mais il n'y a jamais eu de plainte de
par rapport à ce qu'il a fait et
évidemment elle me dit-elle il n'y a
jamais eu de relations avec des mineurs
donc voilà pour terminer sur la version
de l'entourage de et de Sébastien cohet
voilà alors euh donc là là il va se
passer quoi alors maintenant bah là ah
bah là il y a une enquête qui a été
ouverte euh là le procureur a la plainte
de la jeune femme entre les mains et euh
et du coup bah Sébastien cé va être
entendu il y a certainement toutes les
jeunes femmes qui ont témoigné dans le
nouvelops et d'autres qui voudront le
faire qui vont apporter leur témoignage
à cette plainte assez vite cette affaire
ou pas les premières auditions vont
aller très vite hein parce que c'est une
affaire qui est sérieuse général ça
quand même quelques mois mais oui mais
il y aura il y aura assez rapidement des
premières enquêtes des auditions enfin
voilà ça va avancer à partir du moment
où vous avez une plainte et puis il y a
pas de prescription pour les affaires
liées aux mineurs c'est 30 ans mais il y
en a pas donc du coup il y aura une
enquête la police va intervenir et puis
chacun sera entendu et apportera ses
éléments voilà merci allez tout de suite
film